[Musique]
ce soir je veux raconter une histoire
histoire commence en septembre 2011
je suis à milan sur la pièce the world
avec mon copain end street
quand j'ai reçu un email avec cette
image
cette image de la première photo
officielle date une haine à mr tunnel
tout ça existe ans s'était révélé pour
la première fois pour la ministre
italien de l'éducation de l'époque
mariastella gelmini que vous voyez de la
photo
ces tunnels permet l'importation des
neutrinos suisse généré ici au cern à
genève de l'emporter en italie plus
précisément au laboratoire national du
gran sasso ces tunnels
ça fait 7 132 km de la côte d'ivoire la
longueur du tunnel du gothard
ben si vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
de ces tunnels
c'est parce que c'est une elle n'existe
pas et cette image été créée par des
internautes
des gens comme vous et moi tout s'est
moqué de la ministre qui avait monté une
excessive confiance de ses connaissances
scientifiques et d'ingénierie ce type
d'image sont appelés dans le monde
internet même des sons des images
virons virale qui se reprendre très
rapidement ils sont souvent en continu
ironique avec un en textes courts le nom
vient du grec
me ménard limitation en fait on dit que
la modalité avec laquelle ces images
c'est en répondant sur internet pour
clonage mutation aux imitations donc
autour d'eux mêmes sous n'importe quel
sujet ce sujet politique et qu'elle est
aussi sous d'autres choses et en fait la
plupart des mêmes savent à présent
complètement autre chose et là je vais
vous montrer à un exemple de même avec
un sujet un peu plus classique que tous
les gens sur internet adore des chatons
voilà les mêmes fictionnel que je vais
monter c'était les premiers même que
j'ai vu des sujets politiques
mais dans les années suivant j'ai reçu
plein de même politique et j'ai envoyé
moi même de même politique mais un jour
après sept ans j'ai reçu une image a
même entre différents que tous les
autres même la gtc septembre 2018
cette fois ci j'étais à genève en place
durant ce jour avec mon copain est
toujours de spezza de passionnel et
sûrement pour ça que j'ai re voir cette
image du hautement du compte twitter du
ministre de l'intérieur italien matteo
salvini
mais vous inquiétez pas je vais vous
donner la tradition en fait il y à une
enquête parce que son parti est
soupçonné du foie de graver des 49
millions d'euros à l'état italien
une chose importante semaine les
ministres ont sommé par ses photos des
soucis en fait il dit sur twitter oh oh
j'ai reçu une enveloppe fermée au
ministère par le tribunal de palerme des
calanques est je suis l'objet je dis
qu'est ce que vous dites on leur
ensemble
quand j'ai réussi c'est même j'ai
remarqué que c'est un peu différent du
même que j'avais reçue il ya sept ans si
vous les montre en semblant fatigué en
arrivant à la différence ensemble fait
le même et du ciel c'était même créé par
des gens comme nous tous ces mots clés
de la ministre malok même le même délai
enveloppe la secret par les ministres et
pas pour se moquer de quelqu'un l'a bien
sûr main pour se faire de la propagande
alors moi
pour des formations professionnelles
j'adore mais créer des problèmes au mont
plaisant posons des questions j'ai
commencé à me demander mais comment un
outil qui disait par les acteurs autour
des gens qui vont sur internet est
devenu utilisé en fait pour faire de la
satire est devenu un instrument utilisé
par les politiciens même qui en jeûnant
doit être les victimes de ce type
d'image pratiquement comment les
politiciens son entrée dans le monde de
même j'ai commencé à penser à toutes les
choses qui sont changés dans sept ans on
a que le thunder gothard était terminé
après ouais mon copain est plus blanc et
un voilà quand je cherche d'espionner
mes amis sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est devenu très difficile parce que je
suis bombardée par les déclarations des
politiciens ils nous passent le temps à
nous raconter leur vie et ce qu'ils font
donc ils nous parlent de nos engagements
situationnelle de leur projet politique
si par exemple on est combien d'épisodes
de papineau enfants ont regardé la nuit
précédente a faites sont devenus un peu
comme des amis et il nous comprend pas
ce qu'ils font une vie comme l'annoncent
ils ont notre même problème comme nos
jeunes et ils savent que les enfants
pour regarder le même épisode est
peut-être pas pig son temps des foires
sans interruption fait on les sent très
proches et on est plus timide et de leur
poser des questions et lors de nous
répondre directement ces choses
magnifiques enfin c'est une révolution
on peut parler directement aux
politiciens c'est une chose impossible
imaginé il ya dix ans des petits ça ne
sont pas les seuls qui ont changé avec
internet nous aussi maintenant
on n'a pas toute l'information cole a
besoin sur internet s'est assis vous
pouvez taper chercher le sujet vous êtes
intéressé mon peuple j'ai obtenu mon
doctorat
relisons des choses sur internet et si
vous par exemple on ne voulait pas faire
la même figure de la ministre italienne
avec les tunnels vous pouvez juste que
je cherchais physique de notre union et
vous ne me fais pas et comme ça on peut
aussi parler des politiques découvrir
tout sur la politique ça générait en
fait une imitation des experts on n'est
pas ce qui diminue donc pas tous des
experts il ya tant des blogueurs des
journalistes et sympathie venu difficile
de reconnaître un vrai expert données en
pole et se sauve de s'écouter l'un
l'autre chose ok internet a changé c'est
la mémoire dans le monde d'internet tout
est éphémère
un stand à maintenant ça dure combien de
jours toujours fait qu'un enfant peut
plus non mais s'il ya sept ans les
scandales du tunnel en fait de terminer
la fin de la carrière politique de la
ministre
aujourd'hui on dit les scandales se
connaissaient une explosion de même et
en fait souvent les protagonistes de ce
scandale
il devient aussi plus populaire grâce à
leur exposition médiatique
donc on sait tout de ce contest et c'est
effectivement là kioua qu'est la satire
a évolué la sortie internement du peuple
du genre comme nom pour se moquer du
pouvoir pour souligner les incohérences
et les incompétences et des personnages
connus des politiciens maintenant sur
les politiciens même qu'ils font de la
sortie en avion l'exemple du ministre
avec l enveloppe il faire ça pour des
raisons précises fait ça pour minimiser
dale et aussi pour montrer sa force
politique à ses supporteurs donc ils
fois on avait les humoristes qui jouait
sur la scène la partie des politiciens
maintenant on a des politiciens qui sont
lors même les acteurs de cette de cette
pièce donc les praticiens ils font
beaucoup de satire par exemple là et
pourquoi ils font des sorties bars je
dirais pour pour cacher quelque chose
pour attaquer les adversaires pour nous
distraire chose on est bien sûr ils ne
font pour ils ne font pas ça pour nous
faire rire
donc ce que je vous montrais jusqu'à
maintenant sont des mêmes utilisés par
la politique et pas les gens qui se
moquent de la politique donc mais les
politiciens ne sont pas les seuls qu'ils
ont commencé à utiliser les mêmes que
c'est effectivement un vrai moyen des
communications faites nous on a le
pouvoir d'utiliser les mêmes parce que
les mêmes et r1 origines crée pas des
internautes et les entend continuer à
créer et partager les mêmes et on peut
imaginer plein des usagers différents
d'eux mêmes par exemple au port
utilisent les mêmes pour faire de
l'autocritique
si vous êtes italien on peut les
utiliser a besoin pour faire des mondes
de waele elle mais si on peut plus
sérieusement on peut les utiliser pour
enseigner la physique
là on est tous n'importe où les
neutrinos donc si vous ne comprenez pas
ce même je vous conseille de taper ce
soir physique de notre hymne vous allez
en résoudre cette énigme
on va aussi les utiliser pour
sensibiliser les gens à des thèmes
importants en avion plein d'exemples ce
soir l'écologie moi j'adore le chocolat
donc que c'est en partant de ce fait la
planète
et si vous aimez la poésie vous pouvez
aussi les utiliser pour faire de la
poésie y ait un peu plus ironique la
physique classique mais il ya l'espace
pour avoir beaucoup d'imagination et
bien sûr ils vont peut continuer à
utiliser les mêmes pour faire de la
vraie satire de la vel satis contre les
pouvoirs et contre les politiciens
ouais ça c'est beaucoup dans ce genre
sursaut en italien
donc en fait on a on n'a pas des limites
de l'imagination comment on peut
imaginer les âges de même tout le monde
pour les créer sont faciles à faire il
faut être con pour trouver un fort côté
ironique
en fait la seule limite c'est votre
imagination donc bienvenue en même
cassis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]